um
right so just testing once more to see
if this is working
brilliant sorry about that chair and
thank you for your patience
that's okay so do i need to go back to
the beginning
yeah i'm afraid so
uh good morning members good morning
members of the public
you're all very welcome to pay but just
at council's planning committee meeting
on the 4th of november 2020
my first of all remind you of some of
the domestic
arrangements okay good
please ensure that the microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you wish to speak
point of order declare and interest
or request an adjournment please use the
hands up function
on the taskbar
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open other scope chats etc
and that you and that if you are
contacted by a third party during
an application you should bring this to
the legal advisor's attention
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave if members
do lose connection to the meeting that
they must
contact the member support officer mandy
smith
as soon as possible i would like to
remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the beaten will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possibility possible use
of those sound recordings for webcast
and or training purposes
the council members of the pub public
and press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
i'm no longer introduced introduce the
officers present to help
here this morning mark russell area
planner manager bradley heffer
case officer indy press planning lawyer
and robert carmichael
governance officer
i think i'm going to need all your help
this morning
can i name this to the agenda please
you you have it in front of you members
so item number one is substitutes and
apologies
rob are we all present and correct thank
you chair i believe so but we're just
going to run through a very
quick roll call just to
um so that everyone is aware so
councillor sue ayres
president and good morning council
melanie barrett
yes present councillor busby
present council hinton present council
jameson
president councillor mclaren present
councillor osborne good morning present
counselor owen present
counselor parker present and counselor
plum
president thank you chair including
yourself we are all present
thank you very much um
right uh declarations of interest
yeah are there any declare sorry yeah
peter
i've had dealings with the applicants in
my role as director of baba growth this
is the
uh declaration that i also made for the
kersey application so
i'll just ask our league of legends uh
to
give his comments on that indeed
chairman that's a kind of declaration
that quite often has to be made by a
member of this committee who also
happens to be a cabinet member will have
other responsibilities and the council
is
properly made as a non-pecuniary
interest and the meeting can continue
with councillor busby here
thank you good banker councillor busby
any other declarations of interest
no right then we'll move on
uh to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 7th of october to follow but
i think you've all had an email i'll ask
rob to comment on this
thank you chair so um within minutes
i um so we record we have received a
request from
mr russell our area planning manager um
to defer
them um as a point needs to be urgently
checked um and was not available
it was not possible to check this um
before the meeting today so with your
permission chair we would ask for a
deferral on the minutes and bring them
to the next available meeting uh
we don't need to have a vote on this do
we i think um
members it seemed quite sensible that if
there is
um something urgently needed to be
clarified that we need to get it right
before we agree the minutes
are you all in agreements no one's
putting their hand up against so we'll
take that as
uh you're in agreement that uh we'll
wait for
the minutes to come agree yeah okay
thank you any idea when they'll come
back to us
they'll be the next meeting chair it's
just one very specific point
lovely thank you very much
item four are there any petitions rob
none received good item photos site
inspections
none from members uh well actually
peter um i just wonder how many people
on the committee haven't attended the
the previous site meeting we had back in
20 whatever it was 16 17
because this is a significant
application in terms of number
and it's quite a controversial site i
just wonder whether
it would be served better by a site
visit before we
make any further decisions on it it
could delay out a long time but i
i don't know um perhaps mark could say
that
you know maybe we've done a drone flyby
or whatever it isn't got a video
we haven't got a video this time um
counsellor um obviously you know what
the rules are about
doing site visits still and obviously in
the what
the news this week is even less likely
so um no
we can't do a side vision we haven't got
a video of it for you sorry
but it's over 200 how uh
houses effectively with the care home
it's quite a big application just
perhaps members that haven't been
uh counselor
penciller plum do you got a comment on
this what well
i was going to suggest that why don't we
hear the officer's presentation
and then decide if a site visit of some
sort
is is necessary at the moment we're
we're
i'm i am someone who did actually attend
the the meeting
some time ago um and and with the rules
as they are
is it really necessary to to have a side
visit if if we haven't heard the
officer's presentation
i think you've got a very good point
there council plum um
canceler parker on this issue yeah just
on this issue
um i mean i i take councillor buzzfeed's
point but
um i i think i'm right concerned that
this is uh reserve matters isn't it this
this this application so
not notwithstanding it's a very
significant application there's no doubt
about it but the uh
that the site visit itself isn't
actually going to change anything other
than
than viewing it um you know viewing what
we already know isn't it
yep yes i'm inclined to agree with you
there
um yes i think we'll we'll carry on
and have the presentation anyway
um so um
officers any site inspections no i don't
suppose it can be any from your point of
view either
right then we'll move on members
item number six is plan an application
for determination by the committee
and we've got pinewood suffolk 6b
on pages 11 to 32
and the case officer
is bradley heffer um
if you'd like to take us through the
through the um application
uh did is this the point councillor
busby
wanted to come in well sorry to sound
like i'm being
thinking uh nuisance this morning
this is an application that we dealt
with in depth
some time ago and i'm just not
clear as to what it is we're going to be
able to influence this morning
so perhaps if mark could just clarify
that at the earliest part of his
presentation that would be a help i
think
well it's bradley that's doing the
presentation but mark
will actually uh clarify that point as
the chief officer
thank you chad so the previous
application which has the 2014 reference
which um
was heard by committee and given
approved in 2016
that was outlined and the only matter
that was
explicit in the outline permission was
the access the highway stuff that that
was
given permission and effectively
everything else
would be open for discussion but um
the permission did have quite a lot of
restrictive conditions um
chief of which i would say was probably
the um the schedule of accommodation
which um explicitly stated how many two
three four betters there would be
um and that was conditioned in so in
some ways
probably the layout and everything that
you're gonna look at i would guess
couldn't be changed that much um so that
that's a condition to consider there are
other conditions like the story heights
of the of the care home
and things like that but the effectively
the permission was for the access
it was explicitly for a set number of
dwellings not up to but explicitly
155 dwellings and a 65
bedroom care home so the two things that
definitely have permission are those
numbers and the access
and the rest of it is tied into a set of
conditions
but you can discuss um the scale
the design the layout and the
landscaping
thank you right um case officer bradley
would you like to take us through it
thank you very much chair and um good
morning members hopefully with the um
presentation i can give um it'll clarify
some points for you
in order for your debate um if i
can just ask you to clarify whether you
can see the screen
yep you can see that excellent thank you
so i'm assuming everybody can say no
one's
not put any hands up or anything yep
carry on right thank you
um yes the application that you're being
asked to consider this morning
is a reserve matters proposal um
following the grant of outline planning
permission it's a reserve matters
proposal for 135
units a 65 bed
space care home and a cafe on a site
at pinewood off of sprites lane and
cottingham road
plan is an aerial map of the location um
and obviously shows the site application
or sorry the application site the red
dot there is to indicate the position of
bellstead house which is a grade 2
listed building and you'll also note
residential development to the north
and to the east and obviously the a road
network
which is to the west
uh this plan shows the constraints uh
which
may impact on the site those of which
are the the listed building as you can
see here
um the public rights way which don't
actually go through the site
uh the site you're looking at today um
which extends up to that point but they
do certainly pass it on that side
and then you've got public rights away
away
to the west again the other point
i wanted to um just point on this slide
as you can see on here
this line is where the established
settlement boundary is
go up area boundary for this part so
this site is currently outside
this is the layout that's being proposed
for
reserve matters approval it's for 135
units
the overall planning commissioner
outline was for 155
but that included the land you can see
edge blue excuse me which is um
basically bested house uh
and it's immediate environs and you'll
note on this drawing you can see
faintly that there are some dwellings
being shown here
which were part of an approval for in
total
20 units to be provided on here so it's
the residual 135 that are being
proposed under this reserve matters the
means of access to the site would take
place off cottingham road
a single point of access and as my
colleague
mr russell has pointed out that has got
planning permission
so the two things that have planning
permission are the number of units
overall and the means of access
the layout itself is
a perimeter block arrangement towards
the south of the site
which allows for a denser form of
development
to be created and then the residual
development away to the north is a
looser arrangement
from the sort of denser arrangement
you've got here
the other element key element of course
is the care home
at the south which contains the 65
beds you'll note that most of the units
are detached semi-detached
there are some instances of terraces uh
parking is provided mainly on site
but again there are instances elsewhere
where you'll see parking courts
um the other thing to point out is that
the site itself does benefit
from established planting along its
boundaries
along sprites lane and along the
boundary with the
residential development to the north
and that would be unaffected in the main
by the development taking place
this plan excuse me this plan shows the
intended phasing of the works
for the overall development uh part of
which has already got full planning
permission
so phase one of the development would be
bell state house itself
which would obviously take access off of
as is the case at the moment
um off of sprites lane
phase two would be the provision of
this element of the access road which
would then
enable the construction of phases three
and four
phase five would lead off of that
off the end of the phase two road
network
six and seven would follow on uh six
this area of six would serve as the
overall site compound
for the storage and materials and the
last element would be the construction
of the care home itself
this plan shows the alternative
emergency vehicle access
should the access of cutting and road
for any reason become
unavailable for emergency vehicles this
shows the arrangement
for alternative access which is a
requirement of the highway authority
you'll note that where the
site meets up with wilding road
there's a provision of bollards at that
point
and also at the end of the turning head
here where the site meets up with
sprites lane
there's bollards as well lockable
bollards so therefore obviously
pedestrian cyclists can still get
through cars are precluded
but emergency vehicles can get through
if needed
in the event that the access of
cottingham road
wasn't available
this plan and the other or a couple of
other plans following on
uh are useful because they show the
topography of the site
in relation to um the surroundings
there is a significant slope across the
site
from north to south approximate north to
south
the section you see a a for example
is this section here so this runs all
the way down the middle of that
perimeter block street
section b which is the top half of the
cul-de-sac
you can see again runs all the way down
you know in a fairly um significant
slope
and again other sections are taken
through the site
to show how that works um just to give
you a flavor of the topography which is
an element which has to be taken into
account with the development of the site
and again further examples of the um
the site sections these are useful in so
far as
this is the new proposed development
here and
you have existing development um
adjacent and it'll give you some idea of
the
relevant relevant heights in relation to
existing development
and importantly you'll note that this
dwelling here
is at that height this dwelling being
two-story
would come down to here so it'll be sit
lower the garden would sit lower
than this particular building
i'll run through the architectural
approach that's being taken
as i said in my report it's a
traditional form
but it's a modern architectural language
really that's being used
the materials themselves are traditional
the use of brick
render um slates and tiles
um but the the use of fenestration is
a more contemporary approach um and
elements like brick paneling
um have gone into the buildings which
again add visual interest
make them you know rather than the the
general
sort of um residential response
um that is normally made i think that
these add visual interest overall visual
interest through the buildings
again here's some examples of the flat
blocks
in the case of the flats you've got
parking underneath
the flats above which as you recall from
the earlier plan which showed the
parking courts
where you've got flats near to parking
courts that allow some surveillance of
the parking courts themselves which
again
is considered a useful element um
in overall planning terms this is the
cafe building
uh which would sit on the open space
um and again it's a fairly
straightforward building in terms of
design it's a contemporary design it's a
single unit
sorry a single volume building as you'd
expect with the kitchen
and toilet facilities so um it fits in
where we think with the overall design
ethos of the the site that's being taken
is the care home development at the end
um as you may have picked up from my
report
there was a restriction on story heights
in the
um outline application that was granted
um and this is the only element within
the scheme that is
three-story height uh or parts of it
three-story height
other parts two-story it's again uh
following a fairly traditional form in
terms of over organization of the built
form
but it has contemporary feel to it as
well
um and overall would sit we think fairly
comfortably at the end
of that development bearing in mind it's
at the lowest point of the site as you
may recall from
from what i said earlier there's two
not much you can actually read in detail
on there but it's two floor plans
to show how the individual bed spaces
would work
i'll finish off with some photographs
for you this is a lead down this is
taking off
google maps obviously the lead down from
cottingham road into the site you can
just about perceive
a bit of a slope as you go down
from the photograph and again this is
the entrance
leading into the site from cottingham
road
again hopefully you'll get a flavor of
the slope
from the difference in the pier or the
the level of the wall
um as the road goes down beside it so
there is a slope that's being dealt with
here
um these are various views across the
site
itself which is covered by power lines
um the power lines are obviously um
strategic sized ones
as you can see from here so they would
stay in situ
the the development would obviously have
to take those into account
in terms of location of buildings um
it's um benefits as i said before from
the um
the screening established screening this
is heading up towards
bested house bested houses the other
side of this
and there you can see the edge of
existing development
and hopefully get a flavor of the um
the overall difference in height between
the site and as it goes down
um just to give an idea of the
topography
um i think that's all i need to say at
this particular point chair but
obviously
oh sorry last last slide which again is
taken via
google earth because i didn't fancy
wandering along the the a road
but this will give you an idea of the um
the view across
i think that generally extended views of
this site
past the footpath network would be
afforded via the local a-road network
and in this regard i think you can see
where the edge of pinewood
sort of comes in relation to that and
the development
would come down here as i say that that
concludes my
presentation i think that uh just to
reiterate
um from officer's point of view
um i don't think this is
a scheme that needs to be debated in
terms of
principle anymore because the principle
is established
but certainly if members have got
comments with regard
to layout design and the way the site
works things like that
then obviously as a reserve matter
they're part and parcel of reserve
matters consideration
thank you thank you very much for that
members is there um any points to
clarification you'd like
to ask the case officer would you use
the hand function
i've got uh lee jameson followed by john
hinton
lee uh yeah thanks uh
uh if you could um uh what is the
white area next to the um care home
the big white patch on the left of the
care home there
sorry council i should have pointed that
out in my response
that looks a little bit like a solar
farm but it is in fact
um a suds feature um the
actual detailing of that wouldn't look
like that and i think it's uh
um the drawing itself doesn't actually
show that in
in proper detail but bearing in mind the
fall of the land
the actual suds feature would be
adjacent to the care home on that piece
of open space
okay and and one other thing on
back of the care home on the roof are
they windows or solar panels
looking at the drawings um
if i just get the uh can you remember
the slide number
councillor jameson uh i no i didn't so i
think
not too worried that
hinton thank you mr chairman just a
couple of
um quick questions first the uh
mr heffer mentioned when talking about
the
landscaping to the north boundary and to
the
onto the cottingham the north boundary
and also on to
sprites lane uh will be unaffected
in the main by the development what on
earth does he mean by
uninfected in the main because that
sounds like a lovely expression which uh
leaves everything open to
misinterpretation secondly the question
would probably be more addressed to
mark than it would be to mr heifer and
that is that if this was approved in
2016 is it out of time
and lastly um i think it was slide
30 it indicates a an information board
when it's looking out across the
countryside which rather implies that
that is a public open space
already um i understood that there was a
sort of greenways project that went
across most of that green land along
that side of
pinewood between the developments and
the
a14
could he explain uh just what the the
use of that
board is and what when it's gonna be
covered in um houses and concrete
yes thank you councillor um with regard
to the first point um
yeah there was a unfortunate phrase in
the main i think that
the belt of trees for example that's
shown along the boundary here
and and hedging some of that would need
to be cleared
in order for this development to take
place i think the key point is that the
ones
on the edge here serve as a purpose for
screening
um and in in the case of some areas will
be augmented by new planting
so there will be in this area for here
for example in order for these buildings
to sit there
um some clearance would scrub and um
lower vegetation would have to take
place
in any event and the the land level
would have to be leveled out slightly in
order to get the
the development in so that's what i
meant by that
um the application um the reserve
matters application submission
was submitted right at the end of the
period
of the outline requirement uh but it was
submitted in time so it was a valid
uh outline uh sorry valid reserve
matters
application um the third point i think
was to do with the board
um i think there are certainly
interpretation but there's an
interpretation board on the site
and i think there's a finger post on
there as well
but the status of this land isn't pos
it's not public open space
so i think that whilst there is an
interpretation brought on there
um the reserve sorry the outline
application
did establish that you could get
residential development taking place on
that land and it's
it wasn't zoned and it isn't zoned as
public open space now
thank you uh councillor mccallum
thank you chair um bradley can you
tell me if you defined uh
the number of car parking spaces within
the nursing home
boundary
sorry counselor uh yes um on the issue
of
parking in the care home um
unfortunately i did admit that in my
report but
um i can give you a quick breakdown
because i've got a note here somewhere
um just to clarify that
yes if you can clarify that point
further yes
i will do um in relation to the care
home hold on if i
um quickly get back to
ah there it is yeah we're talking about
this area here
within that area um
there are 36 spaces
um the current standards require
uh one space per three bed spaces
and i think in total
um one space uh
sorry one space per full-time equivalent
staff
and based on the number of spaces and
the number of
um you know against that standard
that does actually hit the standard so
um
yeah we're we're happy that the the
amount of space is
in there matches the standard that's
required for the care home
under a certain use because in fact if
it was
over you know if it was over full then
uh visitors and practitioners are going
to park somewhere else on the site
aren't they
yes yeah yeah but we're as i say
yeah okay thank you bradley councillor
ayers
thank you chair um i'm a bit concerned
um as i'm
a um chairman of a residential home in
sudbury the fact that it's three-story
and we had a problem when the one lift
we had broke down
um what what is the arrangements for the
the lifts or
exiting the people if there was a fire
have the fire people being consulted
thank you good point um
thank you cancer yes i think in this
particular case um
we would rely on the requirements of the
building regulations
um i think in terms of building rigs
there have to be
safe means of exit and entrance into a
building
and provision of lifts if necessary
depending on number of
as i understand it number of uh people
in the building and
and floors and things but yes as well as
the principle being established and the
look of the building being acceptable
um you know it would have to record with
the building regs requirements
which includes the um the safety
elements of it
can we come back on that and please
chair
if there is a fire you would not be
allowed to use the lifts
and if some of those people are quite
disabled you would have a serious
problem
so i think we should look into that a
little more thank you
i think about it also counselor airs be
a question you could
um put to the um agent might be a good
point
yeah thank you chair uh councillor
barrett
thank you chair um bradley you mentioned
the heights of the uh buildings in
relation to the neighbouring properties
and shows on your
cross sections um uh that they were
the same or lower um at the
where they where they uh are right at
the edge of the development
um is there any sort of condition that
might be applied to ensure that the
development those houses near the the
edge do not end up being
higher um i mean if the developer has to
suddenly excavate um to ensure that they
are at that
high and and decided not to excavate
could they could they um
could there be a condition attached or
is there a condition attached
yes thank you councillor um as part of
the outline planning permission
um there was a condition attached uh
regarding
higher levels of the site in relation to
existing and finished floor levels
of the buildings that would be built
across the site not just on that
boundary which is
as you say a key point but um yeah
across the whole site and i think
not least that was a reflection of um
the topography issue at the time that
was considered
so there is that control in place at the
outline
stage and you know something that has
been considered as part of this plan
application
okay yes thank you very much thank you
mary your hand's still up did you want
to come back
[Music]
canceling out thank you uh right
uh councillor busby
can you change the small point on page
27
10.4 we're talking about uh acoustic
uh materials and whether offense is
required etc
now the last sentence says uh
the health protection officer
recommended that garden fences should be
of a close boarded type with a minimum
height of 1.8 meters
we're talking fairly small gardens here
and with a minimum height of 1.8
that would make them very very
claustrophobic
i think that should be a maximum height
of 1.8
yes whether you like your privacy i
suppose
anyway um yes uh just
some background for that um council i
think that um
when the reserve matters application
came in i think that my colleague in
environmental health queried the issue
of
noise protection as part of the
discharge conditions application that
was made
and i think that as a result of that it
was
the applicant's acoustic engineers
demonstrated that it wasn't necessary to
put in an acoustic fence
down one boundary with the um the a-road
network for example
but um i think that's a question of
wording in relation to
what you're reading there is um you know
we wouldn't want to see anything more
than 1.8 meters high
because as you say that would be quite
impressive for the people living in
there
if if my colleague is advising me that
1.8 meters high is appropriate
then you know that would be the limit in
terms of the sort of
boundary treatment that we would expect
to see
yeah but in that case i think you should
take the word minimum out i mean
it only takes one and if you if you
drive down
uh cottingham road you will see that it
doesn't only take one person to uh
significantly after the
the visibility attractiveness of
the estate by doing strange things to
the house
and you could imagine somebody putting
up a three meter fence and it would
it would make a mess so i think you
should just take the word minimum out
yeah well i think that um the
landscaping condition that was imposed
at the time of the um outline planning
permission
would have included details of that but
that's certainly a point that
we can consider you know as part of that
discharge of that particular condition
because we're not asking them to
discharge landscaping
per se as part of this reserve matters
approval
because it is covered by the outline
planning permission that was granted
thank you okay
thank you um there's no other hands up
so i'll assume there's no other
questions we'll move on then to public
speakers
and we have parish council
representative
beryl culver to speak you have three
minutes in which to address the
committee
um i'll asked rob to do the time and
thank you
when you're ready so do you
just before we start could we just ask
um mr head for the case office to just
take down the presentation
thank you bradley thank you chair ready
whenever you are
all right let's first get um the parish
council up and running
are you there
i can't see or hear you at the moment
can you hear me now i can hear you yes
uh we still can't uh yes i now see you
hopefully everybody else can they see
you
yes your time hasn't started us don't
worry thank you for
having patience with us um right rob
um when you're ready madam you start
he'll tell you
thank you thank you all right pinewood
parish council wishes to
object to the application on the
following grounds there appears to be a
change from the original planning
statement
that dwellings will be predominantly for
the over 55s
but reserved matters documentation
states that 75 units will be for the
open
and affordable markets and only 57
for the 55-plus demographic the original
argument for this development
was it would cater mostly for this age
group
why has this changed though you say that
access was settled at the outline
stage we've had to seek clarification as
the status and use of sprites lane a
byway
and cottingham road regarding the whole
development
and have yet to receive any clarity
prior to this meeting
para54 of the documentation for the
hearing states that
by way of clarification it is the case
that all the
killer traffic accessing this site would
utilize the approved access
of cottingham road however a response
received by this council to our
questions
to the planning officer about sprites
lane
states that it will provide entry and
egress for the 20 dwellings
linked to bellstood house and it will
also be available
for entry into the site for the
remaining 135
dwellings these statements seem to be
contradictory
and should be clarified if cotting road
is to be the sole access for the 135
dwellings
and care home the council is extremely
disappointed that once again
baber district council has refused to
take into consideration our concerns
as of the suitability of this road for
the extra traffic
a public inquiry some years ago ruled
that because of its widening and steep
nature
resulting in compromise visibility
cottingham road was unsuitable for an
increase in traffic use
the highways department has refused to
consider any mitigation
measures for cottingham road there are
at least already 185 dwellings
currently using this road as it's a
feeder for a number of other roads
and development will cause it to rise to
more than 350.
there i've learned today that there are
36 spaces for care home
that take the development itself to over
at least 150 traffic movements if coffee
and road is to be the sole access
then surely this contravenes suffolk
design policy and guidance
given at the outline planning for stage
that for developments over 150
then two access routes are required no
consideration appears to be given
to the amount of traffic generated by
the care home
of 65 residents cottingham road resulted
to a scrivener drive which is often at a
standstill because of other recent
developments there's also been an
unwillingness to conduct an
up-to-date traffic survey of the area as
it was accepted
that the 2015 survey was full it's time
chair
thank you thank you very much um members
have
any points of clarification you'd like
to ask the
parish council representative
i see no hands up at the moment let me
just see if i can scroll down
there's because there's some at the
bottom
no no there's no one okay i'll take that
this isn't any questions to you
i'll try and put those a couple of
points that you brought up
to the officers in due course right
thank you um in fact
i will ask the officers now um the
the change of the age group from the
over 55s that the parish council
commented about
and also i think she said there was an
increase in the traffic
um of 135 or something
can you possibly clarify on that bradley
yes thank you chair um with regard to
the
the mix um again as um
i think um my colleague said it
basically the the mix of development is
within the section 106 agreement that
was signed
and there is a condition that was
attached to the outline planning
permission
that says that's got to follow what was
actually submitted as part of the
application
so there is no change in that uh from
what was shown
originally um and in truth as i've said
in the report i know that there locally
there is a lot of concern about the
um the traffic generation arising from
this
but that was a point that was considered
at the outline stage
um and i know as part of um
this you know receiving comments on this
that i know local residents do feel very
strongly about that but
did the highway authority have not
raised this is an issue with us
uh you know as part of the consideration
of this reserve matters
they must at the time have considered
that cottingham road and the surrounding
network
was suitable to take the overall number
of units including
of course the 65 bed care home
thank you kenzala parker is yours a ques
a question to the um parish council or
um
yes sharon i've i've come in very late
but i'm wondering that's fine
if you're happy to take the question
perish cancel
can you hear me i can't hear you you're
still muted
no you're muted
i can't hear you yes we can thank you
you're happy to take i'm happy to take
the question it was a bit late but the
council would like to put a question to
you
thank you my best thank you parker
thank you chair and uh apologies um
councillor calva for
late representation but um i just
thought i'd sneak this question in
um only because um if you don't mind me
saying
the um some of the concerns or all of
the concerns that you've raised there
um are very valid concerns around
traffic movements etc
obviously we are here today to discuss
the reserved
the reserve matters so the details of
appearance landscaping layout and scale
um but it appears that you don't have
any objections to those items that we're
deciding today can you just clarify for
us
yes as far as we could see
um having read the um
the the planning documentation and
responses
um we couldn't our main concerns still
focused on
um the lack of clarity we've received
about the
vehicular and um access to the sites
thank you thank you that question thank
you
that question has been answered by the
the officer concerned
um councillor busby have you got a
question for the parish council
well it's just uh help um with the
discussion from beryl that the
site was predominantly for the over 55s
in fact the
there was a section for the over 55s but
the the affordable units were supposed
to be for
for local workers particularly those
that might be working in the
in their care home so i don't think they
were abandoned as over 55s
however i do take odds with what the
officer says about the highways view of
traffic movements
and i'd sympathize with the parish in
terms of
but this this traffic survey was done
on the 23rd and 24th of july in 2014.
i think so need a question to the parish
council or that's
you can take this pint up i'll bring
that in later in that case
thank you very much thank you for your
understanding uh there's no other hands
up
uh parish council so um we'll move on
thank you very much
for taking part i'll now move on
we don't have a supporter so
now i asked the applicant to speak craig
weston and you sir have three minutes in
which to address the committee
i'll ask rob to time you in can you
first of all
uh show yourself and um turn your mic on
and your
camera so that we can see
i can hear you can't see
the camera should be on no it's not at
the moment ah
wait a minute it's come through yes i
can see craig weston
okay rob when you're ready okay mr
weston
okay so good morning chairman and
councillors
i'm craig weston director of uh
windschemer access an
agent for the application uh presented
to you today
the site is owned by the applicant rural
community housing limited
a local family-run business with a
purpose of providing
homes and affordable housing tailored
for local communities
as highlighted in the officers report
this application relates to the observed
matters submission of the outline
approval granted by this committee
in 2016. the outline approval
established the principle of 155 drones
of mixed tenure
and a 65 bedroom care home accessed off
cottingham road and in part sprites lane
this approval has been recognised in the
emerging local plan consultation
documentation
and is included within the build area
boundary of
pinewood and the greatest fringe
we're grateful to the planning officer
and consultees of this application for
working with our design team to ensure
that every effort is made to
refine proposals to address topics
including the drainage
landscaping the highways geometry
and streetscape the application
presented accords with the terms of the
signed section 106 agreement
and maintains the intent of providing a
mixed community
with a focus upon your 50s accommodation
and affordable rented homes
the design of proposals has been
developed to provide a contemporary
scheme with a fabric first approach to
provide modern
efficient homes traditional form but
with contemporary detail
the majority of the properties are two
stories this is combined with a number
of one and two bedroom apartments
comments within the office's report in
relation to bungalows are acknowledged
and the developer in the assistant
instance has taken the approach
of providing homes capable of adaptation
through the inclusion of through the
four lifts
these home interventions follow the
principles of what's known as lifetime
homes
and furthermore flat provision provides
accommodation for those less
mobile the development presented to you
is for the delivery of 135 homes
combined with the already consented
20 new homes to the east part of the
site
the site is in a sustainable location
all constanti responses have been
addressed to their satisfaction
and the science section 106 includes
significant financial contributions to
the local infrastructure
and services and therefore ask that the
councils follow the office's
recommendation
and approve this application for reserve
matters and i'll be here to
answer any of our questions thank you
very much
members does anybody have any questions
for the
applicant the agent sorry
i see no hands yet uh
counselor barrett
uh thank you chair um i wondered if
you'd been working with a
um an established care home provider on
the
the um plan for the care home uh to
ensure that it was
um uh provided sort of suitable
accommodation
um and you know considered things like
ambulance bay
you know um and those sort of issues
that must be very
um very uh important for um
okay home
[Music]
uh we haven't got a care home provider
in place
at this point but as a practice we've
worked
on great number of care homes um so
we're quite well versed in
in the requirements and i'll just take
this opportunity if i may just
clarify that point about uh access and
egress that was raised earlier
so in terms of the lift provision we've
got total number of two lifts
provided in the care home
and and as the officer mentioned we
would be um
obliged to deliver the scheme in
accordance with building regulations
um and it may be as part of that design
the
fire officer will request one of those
lifts to be a firefighting
lift but failing that there will be a
plan in place to ensure safe egress for
all of the residents thank you
mclaren
councillor mclaren yep sorry chair
difficulty with the buttons
mr weston um my
questions are going to be similar to the
previous uh councillors questions
um if you are building a care home
without
any care home provider in that
what recognition of the cqc standards
have been taken into account
can you answer that mr winston so as i
say we're
well versed in the design of care homes
um and we've
applied our experience and knowledge to
that to develop this scheme
and that would be a matter for
compliance with cqc
so this is at this point this is a sort
of planning scheme there will be
other elements that need to be taken
into account with the provider who
acknowledge that
and but the principle of it and the
quantum and the space requirements
we believe accords with those
requirements
because it because a registration
is of obviously this encouragement by
the cqc to be involved in
the early development of any building
and
layout would you accept that
i would accept that
all i would say is that we have been
engaging with care home providers
and given the stage of
this application and
and in terms of the phasing of the
delivery of the site
they'd want to well know that it's
implementable in terms of the access and
that
that is in place before they come on
board so that's sort of where we are so
we have
interest but we don't have one on board
at present
okay can i just discuss with you about
the amount of vehicles that might be
coming into the space
um certainly um the officer
said about the parking space is based on
a
format in my experience
for a 65-bedded care home
there would be actually probably 40
people on site
during the day every day without
visitors and
visiting professionals so i disagree
slightly with the amount of car parking
spaces
but i am concerned about the
access for ambulances and fire tenders
i'm not sure whether your care home is
going to be
linked to the fire service but most care
large care homes
are which means that when the fire alarm
goes off
two fire tenders will arrive uncalled
for
and um that can cause problems
looking at the access on the site that's
a lot of
vehicles if you then add ambulances for
patients or
residents who frequently go to hospital
um councillor mclaren it's obviously a
very good and important question but
um i've got um mark russell the officer
who wants to help out on this yeah yeah
but i'll then go
and ask the applicant afterwards if he
wishes still to comment yeah all right
okay thank you very much
um officer russell yeah thanks chair i
think you probably can guess what i'm
about to say
um and the concerns are understood but
as a general rule
if there's other legislation covering it
then we don't duplicate it in planning
so the care quality commission that's
dealt with elsewhere and certainly
building regs that's dealt with
elsewhere
if if the care home did not comply with
the measures which the council is quite
rightly talking about
they wouldn't get a license they
wouldn't be able to run they wouldn't
get a fire certificate and all that so
that's dealt with by that legislation
and whilst we can think about it and be
aware of it it shouldn't
inform our decision here okay thank you
very much thank you
um i've got two more speakers uh hands
up but
um mr weston did you want to make any
comment on on what the counsellor
had asked although we have had the um
planning officer help out
no then i'll move on i've got
thank you i've got next um
who was it canceller busby followed by
kenzler jameson
just a couple of design queries really
um on
in 2.9 it mentions that metal cladding
would also be utilized on some units
i wonder if you could just explain that
to us because we're not used to that
kind of thing and then in 6.7
you talk about some flats and cart large
units which consist of residential
accommodation located above garages
what kind of insulation would you be
using because it can be very cold
above an open car
good point thank you councillor
yes so the the metal cladding aspect
that relates to um
largely the dharma window
construction details and all the sort of
projections that you
may have seen on the care home building
so to tie them together
we would use a sort of powder coated
metal or zinc product
which would be akin to sort of lead
lead detailing but it's much more
lighter weight and
is less prone to lead theft so it's not
it's not on the elevations as such as a
cladding wrap it's it's
on particular discrete elements of the
design
um the other comment in respect of cart
lodges
and insulation levels again you know to
come down to building regulations and
the um sort of our anticipation
providing high quality
fabric first approach so we would be
using
uh most likely pir insulation within the
floor zone between garage and the
accommodation and
likewise within the roof construction
hopefully that answers that point thank
you
councillor jameson followed by kenslot
osborne
thank you chair uh morning mr weston um
the police have highlighted a number of
concerns particularly around the parking
and alleyways i wonder if they've been
looked at
and it's actioned at all
uh yes i believe those comments came in
prior to a number of changes that we
made
with with the officer in terms of the
the parking courts and so on so we
reconfigured some of the
street scenes so that those areas were
passively surveilled and the neighboring
properties of the look
uh parking areas so that street so
many of those areas have been taken into
account uh
and we've also got um segated access to
to gardens and so on
in in terms of that security point as
well
and okay and another point like if
you've got a lot of pv panels on
a lot of the roads which is good but i
wondered why you've not done
every roof i mean
even somehow she's pointing in the same
direction they've not all got them
every property does have pvs it just may
be that they want a
uh different elevation so i was looking
at the drawing it doesn't look like they
do but they do do they so yes i believe
so
yes it should do every property within
our uh sustainability appraisal and
documentation that we submitted
includes pv provision all right
and um the the um av parking point as
well
uh well at the time of the consent
i don't think that was a requirement but
not not precluding it um it may be
something that could be
implemented and as many of the
properties have on block parking
they will be able to um you know install
a localized
ev charging point for their own turtle
each parking
thanks thank you councillor osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman i'm just um
just a question for the paul craig
um the area of area of land the site
surrounding 4.2
hectares can he just uh
tell me exactly in size the play area
because
you say 10 percent what would be that
what
area of of that land is uh is
in in acreage or in in meterage
the lap the 10 open space provision
please craig
mr weston yes sorry i don't have that uh
figure immediately in front of me but
the play area
is the area near the cafe community
space
um and that that is the public open
space
so i think i believe officers may have
that information i was just gonna say
do our officers have that information
bradley or mark i think you're gonna
have to ask bradley for that um
i'm looking at the moment chair
hopefully i should be able to provide
that information
imminently i'm just checking the right
drawing okay
no no we're trying to help you mr weston
and can i the other part that question
would be
as well the um area of maintenance for
that area is that
going to be taken on by a um
[Music]
management yeah it's not nothing to do
with baby correct
uh council i believe that is all
included as part of the section 106
agreement so it will be a
management company uh with an aspiration
as councillor busby picked up on we're
hoping to provide
accommodation for key workers on the
site
and you know the aspiration will be one
of those maybe a
gardener themselves thank you officer
heffer have you got the answer
thank you chair yeah um it's annotated
on the drawing counselor as being
1588 square metres
open space village green that's how the
annotation reads
okay um now no more
hands uh uh my officer robert
carmichael you've got your hand up thank
you chair it's just a point to bring to
your attention that we've had whether
councillor hinton has just had to leave
the meeting on an
unexpected um call so um
he won't be able to take part in the
debate
or vote because he was not here for all
the information
just to point out now okay thank you
very much yes he does have
or can have some personal problems at
the moment
our thoughts are with him um right any
other
um questions to the
uh agent no i see no hands up other than
mary's but i think it was left up
um uh peter i can see melanie barrett's
hand up i don't know that's
um left over and adrian osborne's as
well uh
adrian's just spoken i haven't got
melanie's up
no then my screen is yeah sorry
uh adrian your hands still up if you'd
like to put it down that would be
helpful
right i'm assuming there's no one else
to ask you questions so i'm going to
move
on i will now ask the ward member
seth norman councillor sec norman to
speak you sir have five minutes in which
to address the committee
uh is he present he is not present chair
i'm afraid um he has sent his apologies
um that he couldn't be here today um
so if you're happy here i will move on
and read the statement that we've
received from councillor
rick hardacre uh right well i'll go to
the next one then the other ward member
who can speak counselor rick hardaker
uh has five minutes addressed the
committee and he's not present
either but you do have a statement to
read on its behalf
yep i'll read that now chair thank you
very much so
uh message from council hardacre i'm
afraid i won't be able to make it to
today's
planning meeting but i want to say that
i completely agree with and support the
objections of both pinewood
and sprawton parishes i live very close
to this site and have done so since
2014 i simply cannot understand how
anyone can walk down cottingham road
through the wooden gate and gaze at the
view across the valley towards bellstone
taking in the trees shrubs and long
grasses of the suffolk countryside
and think to themselves let's concrete
over this
countless people from pinewood boxed in
by dual carriageways
retail parks and urban sprawl found
solace in this space during the summer
months
i saw a deer here in the middle of
lockdown
it is the gateway to the brookside green
place
binding all the way from here to the
orwell
i urge the planning committee officers
and rural community housing limited to
work together to preserve this space
it needs to be kept rural for the
benefit of the community
with housing limited to small-scale
development
in the enclosed area to the north and
that's
that's where it concludes chair thank
you thank you very much
well members i think you've heard that
so we will note that
he's not here so we can't question it um
we'll now go into debate again
uh perhaps you can use the hands up
function but i will just start with
the first alphabetical name which is
cancellers
because i see now her hands up
cancellers
did you want to comment uh not at the
moment i'm thinking
thank you anybody else
uh cancel a busby
yeah jeff i could go back to the point i
was going to make
um which is really why i asked the
question at the beginning about what we
can
approve what we can't approve and what
our scope is
because as i was saying the the traffic
survey that was done
for the original application was done on
the 23rd and 24th of july in 2014.
well two points about that one is it was
in the middle of the summer holidays
so therefore no traffic for suffolk won
and there was a lot of people away on
holiday of course so
it would be impacted by that so much
reduced numbers
and it was 2014 so six years ago now six
years may not sound like a lot
in some areas but in that particular
area and at that particular time
when highways commented on their traffic
survey
there was no woolsey grange
there was no they couldn't have taken
that into account
that was 1200 houses there was no 250
houses designated in cop duck and
washbook 715 cables and mary
there was the no aldi superstore there
was the no pub no restaurant
no vets no suffolk one at full capacity
so the traffic survey that they used in
2014
now is totally irrelevant totally
irrelevant
and really i think
it ought to be redone at an appropriate
time
to justify the ability of traffic to
move out of the proposed estate
i like the design i like the estate as i
said before it's just in the wrong place
if um people don't know cottingham road
which is one of the reasons why i
suggested a site visit if you could get
up google
google maps to see where it comes out
it's almost on the roundabout
the cop dock roundabout which is an
extremely busy
roundabout the tesco's roundabout and
people can queue there for
you know half an hour to get out so
my concern is that the traffic the
transport
in that particular area and i think we
should
do another transport survey and
therefore i propose that we
defer this until that's been done
thank you i'm gonna ask um the officers
um whether they want to comment on that
before i go for a second there
okay uh ken uh
sorry um officer bradley
thank you chair um i don't know um mark
may have further comments on this but
um all i can say in terms of um
sorry i'll switch my camera on as well
all i can say in terms of um
the comments that counselor busby has
raised
again is to reiterate that as
the outline application was approved
you're not considering issues of
traffic generation under the reserve
matters proposal
now if you feel that the um the reserve
matters proposal
needs alteration because of various
issues that's fair enough but
my advice is that we haven't had an
objection from the highway authority
um the fact that this has an
outline application would be factored in
as part of loading onto the
um highway network in relation to other
newer developments that have taken place
in the area so the highway authority
would have had to have taken that
into account older thought um and
again our advice from that authority is
not that
this is going to cause a traffic problem
so i as i said before i acknowledge the
comment
that is not something unfortunately that
um
is something we feel that we can support
as planning officers
thank you um officer russell did you
want to make any
uh comment i was going to say the same
as what brad just said chair basically
the the conversation about the validity
of the travel
of the of the assessment of traffic it
was done then it was accepted by
committee members then i know it was six
years ago but on that basis we have an
outline permission for this number of
houses
so we can't really see that now no thank
you um so i'm going to ask my legal
adviser
um in through that there's been a
recommendation put forward i know i
haven't asked for secondary yet
um do can this
be ruled out in view of the fact that um
we're discussing certain points um and
highways have made all their comments um
what is your view on a deferment
well what sorry chair has
i i must have i i was trying to follow i
i may have
lost lost the threat at one point that a
proposal has been made
i haven't had a second app and just
remind me who made it who made the
counselor and that was for a defer for
the
decision on the question of the traffic
and wanton more up-to-date traffic
survey
the officer's advice which i endorse um
very firmly is is that um we we have
as the uh as mark and bradley have said
we have
an outline um consent
which is well beyond any legal challenge
or anything like that
um we the applicant is entitled to
expect that reserve matters approval
will be granted to put that into effect
there may be arguments about the all the
all the matters that we've been
discussing today
scale design layout landscaping reserve
matters approval can be
refused if the decision maker in this
case committee thinks
any of those are inappropriates wrong um
but i think
well i think if if a resolution is port
and if it gets
then it must be voted on i think it's
just that the
officer's advice is very clear that this
is uh this would be a difficult
one to put into effect that's all we can
say really is officer thank you
uh right cancer buzzfeed i'm going to
come back to you do you wish to pursue
your
request for deferment on the reasons
you've already stated
difficult i know that's what i've got
put back to you
it's uh i mean i always think of the
phrase that when you're in a hole stop
digging
um but i'm not necessarily thinking that
replies to me but i'm thinking about
when we get in a hole in in pinewood we
should stop adding
extra housing to it because it's bad
enough as it is without adding any
any more but if the officers are saying
that we've got no room to maneuver
on this point then there seems little
point
in asking for a deferment but i
can i just have mark confirm that
there isn't uh an angle that we can use
to
defer it for this reason i think he's
made that quite clear but
mark i i can't think of one counselor
sorry
i think you know the discussion was had
to outline um the following
applications elsewhere took into
consideration the permissions that were
existing so
the highway authority would have been
aware i can say you're getting nods from
the legal
people yeah i think i think that as i'm
sure mark would agree the the outline
consensus the applicant may expect the
135 units and the the
the 65 bed care facility and the
the access to be provided it's only if
you think there is a reconfiguration
of of the design and layout that would
lead to a different highways
result and i'm i'm not hearing that at
all i don't think i don't think you are
mark
either so yeah all right thank you i
think okay
i withdraw my my proposal in that case
thank you very much councillor buzzfeed
we have councillor parker next
uh well you did chair but since
councillor busby has withdrawn his
proposal
um i'd i've no need to speak i mean i
will just comment on
on the fact that i absolutely concur
with the officers here
um and um you know uh council busby's
withdrawn so we don't need to uh to
labor on the point at all but the
question is is
you know if you take that to the logical
conclusion you know where would we have
gone with that i'm not sure there was a
logical conclusion but anyway
it's not on the table anymore so i'll
leave it there chair thank you thank you
any other members wish to
comment i see no hands up
uh oh counselor barrett
well it looks as though we have to um
move to a vote
if there is no debate uh well i haven't
had a proposal yet
well one way or the other i will propose
approval
of the uh application um
in line with the officer recommendation
uh taken
the point on board about the fence
to be a maximum one point eight
yes yeah yeah yeah that's a small point
but uh yeah
um right thank you yeah as opposed to a
minimum 1.8
that's right wasn't it yeah that's
correct thank you very much
councillor barrett do i have a second up
please
counselor jameson
um well you can prepar you can propose
that in a moment
and i've seen no reason why that can't
be added in but uh i just need a second
councillor parker has come back i think
chair i'll um i'll second the proposal
but i'm interested to hear what council
johnson has to say
yeah i i think your point on um
electric charging points uh could be
very effective
um so it's over to you now
oh yeah yeah i could say if um
if the approval goes forward can we have
a condition
that the electric uh ev parking points
are put in for the um properties
i don't know if it can be done for all
of them but there are parking spaces
isn't there um what what is the
officer's view on that and then i'll see
whether the proposal and sector will
accept it i think it's a good idea um i
well my understanding of what mr weston
said chair was that they are certainly
open to that
approach um particularly in cartilage
um provision um so i can't see that that
would present
any problems in terms of imposing that
sort of condition
one thing i should have mentioned in my
um presentation which i didn't
is one of the suggested conditions in
the report relates
to a construction management plan which
is very important
that is already covered by the outline
and also the section 106
so that doesn't need to re that doesn't
need to be repeated in the
reserve matters if you're minded to
accept the recommendation so i thought
it's just
useful to point that out as well yeah so
going back to the electric charging
points we
uh you're saying that the likelihood is
that we get some of the electric
charging points put in in certain
percentage areas yeah yeah i think
that's most likely
the most we can do at this stage but i
think there's a point we need to try and
uh flag up when the outlines and what
have you come forward in future
councillor jameson are you happy with
that
um yeah that's the best we can do that's
fine yeah i'll ask the
proposer counselor barrett and then the
second to councillor park or whether
they're prepared to accept that
as part of their proposal councillor
barrow
uh yeah i mean i'd like to see electric
charging points
um on you know a few sites
i suppose um perhaps adjacent to the
care home for
workers who are attending work um
i'm not sure about every house no and i
think we have to be realistic
but um yeah i would like to see some
available
for for people to use cancer parker
yeah absolutely support that chair and
thank you to council jameson for raising
the point thank you
good okay members um
oh councillor osborne i see you've got
your hand up
yeah thank you mr chairman just just one
point uh as regards to the ecology and
biodiversity
could i could i ask that the uh
conditions uh or a an agreement with
the developer that the swift boxes
or swift brooks bricks are put into the
housing areas that he is proposing uh
to um as as in other as in other uh
applications that have gone forward
could i ask that uh
his approval of that and that of the
proposal and secondary
thank you uh uh
officer bradley uh is that taken care of
in the conditions it isn't taken care of
and that's a that's a good point cancer
osborne i think that
because these are constructed in masonry
it didn't
again i don't think that'll present a
problem with the the developer actually
according with that with swift boxes so
i feel confident we could add a
condition to that effect without
creating any issues
yeah you're quite right bradley the the
position with uh
swift boxes they don't have to be brick
they can be put into
areas of other uh develop you know
development of those uh designs thank
you
so so long as we're realistic are you
happy with that counselor barrett
uh yes that that's um i support that
good counselor parker yeah absolutely
and again
thanks the council respond yeah that was
a good point as well
right i uh don't see any more hens up
anywhere
so uh
right then members i think we've got to
the end of it we'll go to the vote now
i will ask the governance officer
robert carmichael to do a roll call
and um we will then vote
over to you robert thank you chair just
before we go to the vote could we just
have
um a brief clarification on the exact
wording for
um the electric vehicle charging
condition
just so that all members are clear on
what we're voting for
i think it was um that we'd like to see
some
but we are being realistic about it
wasn't that correct councillor jameson
it was yes yeah yes thank you i think we
just need something a bit more
concrete um just to make sure that um
when it goes in the midst that that can
be
um and the decision well i think i think
it's gonna should we just have a chair
sorry chess we just have a condition
saying um a scheme for
shall be agreed you know leave it like
that a scheme for it shall be agreed and
implemented
yeah as agreed you know is that okay
well i i think that's acceptable because
um we're not going to be
unreasonable but we don't expect them to
be unreasonable
okay thank you everyone who's happy if
that's agreed then i will go to the vote
so if members could please respond with
for against or abstain so counselor suit
heirs
four councillor melanie barrett four
councillor peter beer four
counts to david busby four
okay how's the john oh counselor hinton
is um as we've
previously discussed cannot take part
counselor lee jameson
four castle mary mclaren
four councillor adrian osborne
four council alice known
four castle lee parker
four and councillor stephen plum four
thank you chair i make that unanimous
before this is the legal advisor i agree
it was unanimous vote for
thank you thank you very much well
members
we've got to the end um
of today's schedule um the date of the
next
meeting uh i did say somewhere
it's the 18th chair 18th of november
okay so unless you're any different
we'll be back here on the 18th thank you
very much
and good day to you all thank you